what's fundamental obviously me to give
you an obvious example there are now
tens of thousands of people who can look
in our magazine and see my email address
and send me an email and let him do and
I read them and they all expect me to
respond that day now ten years ago they
could all send me a letter who's more
work and people for some reason much
it's funny it wasn't that much more work
but many fewer people did it something
about the speed of the internet causes
people to communicate with you much more
often so just the volume of information
I get every day is probably tenfold what
it was a decade ago that's a challenge
on the other hand I've got a cell phone
here and I've got the phone number of a
taxi driver in Bangalore India if I call
him that signal doesn't pass through a
single piece of equipment designed more
than a decade ago everything it goes
through is new on the other hand the
electrons that are coming into this
studio and enabling you to talk to me
come from the Indian Point nuclear power
plant whose basic design dates back to
the 1960s and they pass through a bunch
of electromechanical switches between
indian point in this studio that were
designed 80 years ago there is a huge
disparity between the new economy and
the old economy and the old economy is
the one that is built on using up stuff
the new economy is built on aggregating
information I mean Google is the
ultimate example you sit down I enter
something some obscure technical
publication from a Danish magazine
published in nineteen eighty and
uploaded in 1998 and they find it and
ten thousand other things on the same
topic and then up at the other end says
point 01
seconds that is a very different world
than the world of a crucial here at
nuclear power point